I want to bring in tim cavanaugh we
usually bring in calais aw when there's
trouble with the Dallas Cowboys never
when things are going well the star of
around the horn he'll be visiting the
Cowboys camp coming up on Sunday and of
course Dallas Morning News columnist Tim
Calvo Shawn joining us on the program
Tim how's morale with the Cowboys oh I
think morale will be okay I think
players you know ride through these
things pretty comfortably and since
nobody really knows what's going on and
since he's a running back and doesn't
need to be an ox not at all I think
they'll be able to get their work in but
morale around you know Cowboys fans
there's always a little bit of paranoia
when these things happen everybody
immediately kicks back to Emmitt Smith
yeah Wade murder and I were the the cub
reporters for the Dallas Morning News
covering this team and so we all have
memories of that but I think this will
be a drastically different situation is
he worth the big money though Tim that's
the bigger picture that I don't know if
people are addressing is he a 20 million
dollar a year 18 million dollar year
running back I'm one of the few arguing
no although I don't know everybody it
favors getting paid would go that high I
lean towards not all the way I lean
towards the the analytics crowd that
suggests he's not worth it
and that running backs in general are
not worth it and I've always thought the
way they use it only back in the league
read 300 carries last year that's not to
mention 77 catches two more years to go
on his contract and then they could
franchise it for year they seem intent
to run him into the ground the first
five or six years you know get
everything they can't out of him
and then have a decision to make is he a
lead at this point is he a declining
back at this point because that's just
the way the NFL looks at these these
guys even the really even the great ones
like like Zeke but also you have an
owner and you know he's desperate for a
Super Bowl and more so than any other
owner probably
what role does his personality play in
getting this done or not getting missed
I mean he's it's is he gonna be a hard
line guy because he doesn't strike me as
being a hard line guy you know that yeah
that's funny he was in the first few
years here Jerry Jones kind of was and
he had some contentious negotiations
with other players beyond him it and now
they haven't had that they haven't
really fought anybody in years you know
and that's the best things ek is going
on his side not just the personality
part but the cowboys believe this year
can be something they went out for a
change inside guys on one-year contracts
Robert Clinton from the Dolphins Randall
Cobb from the Packers to fill some holes
which they don't normally do and they
got dak playing out his deal and they
got Jason Garrett as a lame-duck coach
and they feel like this is an enormous
opportunity so they don't want to blow
it by starting the season with Mike
Weber's they're starting running back
and so Zeke knows he's got that on his
side I think a Super Bowl quality team I
think they're one of the four top teams
in the West in the NFC maybe five and I
don't know I don't even know if I'm
putting the Rams in there because I
don't know what to make it talked early
at that whole situation but I mean
they're there where they were last year
and maybe a little better than that
there what's the second round they feel
like I I feel like they're a little bit
in that but I don't know if they're as
good as the Eagles I think the Eagles
are just one notch ahead of them and
obviously those two games they play with
each other will decide a hell of a lot
if you had to pay one there their value
their market value dak zeke i guess you
can throw em are you in there but it's
really about dak and Zeke who do you
want to pay market value for I want to
pay market value for doc Prescott partly
because of the situation they don't have
any alternative they don't have anybody
behind him the Cowboys never carry a
backup quarterback who's plated down in
the league and so life without dak would
be a lot more uncomfortable
life without Zeke wouldn't be great but
you have you know we all have this in
our mind how great he is but you also
have to look at you know the year he was
suspended six games Alfred Morris and
Rod Smith
that's about as pedestrian as it gets
they had higher yards per carry running
behind this line then then Zeke did I'm
not saying there is good but a lot of
people can get get your 4.2 yards
running behind this this line is he got
four seven last year these great thing
is volume you can he can keep carrying
the ball and and you know get twenty
some touches a game and these other guys
can't but but I think life without DAC
for this team would be just to complete
crapshoot and where do we stand with the
dak Prescott negotiations I mean I think
those will get done I think they've
blown that I think they they needed to
get that done early before these other
contracts came in and and when Scott
paid like he did I I don't know that it
makes sense to pay back in the 28 to 30
million rains per year and 80 to 90
million dollar guaranteed whatever
that's going to be but that's where they
are that's why I don't think they really
need to rush on that because it's not
going to go up the rest of this season
there aren't other players to come along
yeah all those guys who could have done
contracts Russell Wilson and wins they
got done but you know he's going to get
overpaid a little bit but I but I think
they can they're in a position now they
can live with that
talking to Tim Keller Sean Dallas
Morning News and ESPN's around the horn
star what's your favorite Dallas Cowboys
story favorite story on and on or off
the field I came because you've been
around this team for 30 years haven't
you yes so I would go back I would go
back to the nothing I'm old of course
the 1986 first year on the beat when
they signed hersa Walker and that was
right after the USFL folded and in fact
I wrote
very tellingly Herschel Walker you know
his Asia was in Thousand Oaks Herschel
Walker's agent extra hammer you know in
negotiations this won't happen overnight
they announced the contract at ten
o'clock the next morning so I said what
10:00 a.m. is not really overnight they
needed some of the morning to get this
out but the main part was when that
happened and they gave Herschel Walker
five years five million dollars
guaranteed the Cowboys went nuts and in
those days we could just wander
everywhere we ate the cafeteria where
the players did you could sit right down
with them if they'd have you and I went
in town Tony Dorsett in the cafeteria
and I gave him you know Herschel's
details and Tony's this way of talking
and he said if these numbers are correct
then yours truly is upset you can quote
me on that
he was always yours truly was that your
headline that was the lead that Doug
Cosby was the tight end Doug Cosby
walked out of kid I don't even remember
why the tight end would have walked out
example of rehearsal Walker field but I
mean it was just all hell breaking loose
and that was my first year on the beat I
was like what the world is you know what
am I doing here this was crazy but you
know I thought things would never get
bigger than that and then of course
Jerry and Jimmy came along and it just
seemed like something every year made it
you know magnified but do you think that
history will when we look back that
Jerry Jones will be credited or blamed
with what happened with the Cowboys I
think I think later on he'll get more
credits for those early years he did it
at the very least even if you're the
biggest Jimmy Jimmy defender of the
world he hired Jimmy he brought him in
and he led him to do his job so it's
very least he did that he's got that
that's sort of what DeBartolo has with
with bill walls he at least had the
vision to do that whether the vision was
really just this is a guy big football
with his arsenal
let's give this thing a try you know the
rest of his stuff and we've talked about
this here before it's all the business
of the NFL which he is he is number one
at making money at bringing in money at
seeing new ways to do things you know
taking the TV contract from CBS to Fox
those aren't really football matters and
making the Cowboys better but they're
but they're huge in terms of making the
league what it is today oh I think he'll
be thought of fondly when you know you
have people look at the business model
and what he did but I think you can
blame him and you can credit him for the
Cowboys and increasing that value but
you know the product they put on the
field and you know I have to blame him a
lot for what has happened here in the
last what 15 years where 23 years since
identity championship and if they never
come out of that then then it's always
going to be very fairly said ever since
Jerry really became the general manager
really you know stayed away from strong
football coaches except for one brief
period with Parcells
and let you know Jerry and Steve and
Randa the show that they that they
didn't get it done and that'll be
that'll be a big black mark on his
career I'll leave you with this the
starting tailback for the Cowboys week 1
is oh ok you know I really can't imagine
this gets that now if you ask me about
the Chargers I might not say Melvin
Gordon that's a different situation but
I I don't think like you said earlier
Jerry doesn't really have the stomach
for these fights he's whatever he is
late seventies and he wants to win a
Super Bowl for all the reasons we just
discussed and you know so Zeke will be
there safe travels out there to cowboys
camp and always great to talk to you Tim
thank you sir that's Tim Calhoun Sean
Dallas Morning News and of course one of
the stars of around the horn for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]